la tour eiffel le château de versailles
ou encore le mont saint michel plus de
117 monument en miniature sont à
découvrir ou à redécouvrir au parc
france miniature à elancourt il a
rouvert ses portes le samedi 9 avril
c'est l'occasion de re découvrir des
monuments qu'on a croisés au cours de sa
vie ça rappelle autant d'émotions qu'il
ya eu deux voyages qui a eu de partage
et pour cette année 2022 une nouveauté
l'ouverture d'un espace de jeu koh lanta
pour les enfants et les adultes cette
année on a en effet l'occasion d'ouvrir
une nouvelle ère de jeu qui se veut une
zone humide on va pouvoir s'arroser ou
éviter les gouttes en tout cas puisque
on propose à nos visiteurs de partager
les aventures de koh lanta et à travers
des certaines épreuves du jeu et
l'objectif étant pour chacune des
équipes de sortir le moins mouillé de l'
aventure qu'on va retrouver évidemment
des marqueurs que sont la plage l'eau la
mer les zones humides avec la pluie et
le beau temps en tout cas le beau temps
pourra difficilement contrôler ça se
fera naturellement tout cas la pio pour
à la maîtriser et et pouvoir s'amuser à
s'arroser et ce défi est donc c'est
vraiment pour tous les âges en plus de
cette nouveauté les visiteurs pourront
retrouver 25 attractions et expériences
ludiques adaptées aussi pour les enfants
la billetterie est déjà ouverte déjà des
réservations et puis des billets
prévendus mais qui sont pas datées donc
mais qui courent sur cette période de
d'ouverture entre début avril et la mi
mai donc on aux estimations nous donne à
peu près un démarrage autour de 1000
visiteurs jour entre avril et les
vacances de toussaint le parc espère
accueillir environ deux cent cinq mille
visiteurs en attendant à l'occasion du
week-end de pâques france miniature
propose le 16 17 et 18 avril une chasse
aux oeufs et un jeu de piste